m
[Musique]
depuis la nuit des temps pour se nourrir
il n'y avait qu'à se servir puis on a
inventé les hypermarchés et la
mondialisation
aujourd'hui la mode est aux circuits
courts mais quels circuits courts
voici trois façons originales de court
circuiter les intermédiaires
nous sommes au nord du loiret la famille
ben possède 90 vaches laitières mais
depuis quelques mois la production de la
ferme a bien changé c'est en voyant un
article sur un journal qu'on a vu que
une start up nous proposait de faire des
yaourts in new look contenaires donc
on s'est montrés intéressés avec mon
frère et en plus notre belle soeur ma
belle soeur a été intéressée pour
occuper le poste donc on l'a on s'est
posés les candidats et c'était parti
quand il a fallu trouver un emploi pour
mathilde les frères ben ont donc parier
sur l'innovation une start up lyonnaise
leur a fourni clé en main une mini usine
de transformation du lait en yaourt
qu'ils commercialisent même ce container
de 10 mètres carrés est aujourd'hui le
royaume de mathilde
[Musique]
avant j'étais opticienne donc rien à
voir et g
libéré un petit peu plus de temps pour
la vie de famille et donc c'était
l'occasion de revenir sur l'exploitation
de pouvoir organiser un peu le planning
peut-être un peu plus la start up pour
ni le container mais aussi les arômes
naturels
sur les 800 mille litres de lait produit
par la ferme sur une année quarante
mille sont utilisés pour faire les
yaourts une très bonne affaire pour les
producteurs de lait
on double la marge brute powell la tna
rejet direct à lire elle est plus élevée
on peut revendre les jours que mon oncle
est un logiciel
l'industriel fait cette marche là pour
lui que là on les appelle on se fait
plaisir
se passer des produits industriels
c'est ce qui anime morgan nommé chef à
domicile à tour aujourd'hui la rendez
vous sur le toit de ce hlm là c'est la
moyenne d'accord
après ayem coeur de boeuf pour qu on a à
peu près neuf variétés la peur coeur de
boeuf par deux primés lors de crimée
marmande ouais c'est audrey qui fait la
visite des 800 m² de serres qui coiffe
cet immeuble de 76 logements sociaux la
production vient tout juste de démarrer
mais le cuisinier est très intéressé
vous appelle tête de trois jours à
l'avancé puis
d'accord s'occupe de tous les légumes et
vous pouvez venir chercher votre panier
pour récolter le jour même ok y'a pas
d'un port c'est chez nous c'est local et
ça c'est important
les jardins perché un projet du bailleur
tour habitat sont gérés par le lycée
agricole de fondettes les fruits et
légumes poussent ici en hydroponie c'est
une technique de culture hors sol on
n'utilise aucun substrat de type de type
terre tout se passe dans l'eau les
plantes elles poussent directement dans
l'eau les racines dans l'eau et le but
ça va être de venir oxygénée cette eau
pour avoir suffisamment une bonne
alimentation pour les plantes
cette critique qui peut être fait des
fois hors sol de dire ça pas debout sa
part au final ce qui n'a pas de goût
c'est des fois ce qui vient de plus loin
qui est que y'a bon maturité et qui est
des caractéristiques qui vont être
choisis c'est justement quelques 7
transportable nous on peut l'accueillir
juste avant qu'elle soit enfin type
quand elle est vraiment mûr et juste à
la joute à descendre quatre étages
en bas les espaces verts ont aussi été
remplacées par des cultures comme ses
pommes de terre qui ont suscité quelques
interrogations chez les locataires
vous aviez des personnes qui étaient
extrêmement intéressé par le projet qui
ont tout de suite en fait eu la volonté
d'aller travailler avec nous participer
des activités acheter nos produits puis
d'autres personnes qui restent encore
quand même assez réticente et
c'est aussi notre travail en fait
d'aller les voir les sensibiliser
au lit s'attelait à la taille côté rue
ce sont des poiriers qui poussent sous
les fenêtres des habitants
et quand même des attaques de pucerons
quand même quand j'ai su nous visiter le
logement et on m'a dit voilà il y aura
des bons fade et des légumes tout et il
pourrait même acheter
je dis ça c'est valable
et c'est vraiment bien
la production est réservée en priorité
aux locataires de l'immeuble difficile
de faire un chemin plus court entre le
produit et son consommateur
mais l'imagination et la volonté ne sont
pas l'apanage des villes à la campagne
aussi on a des idées or gorin élèves dé
vos autres sologne et berry et elle fait
tout de la naissance de l'animal à la
vente au détail de la viande
j'aime être dans la nature
m'occuper des vaches c'est ce que j'aime
le plus j'élève des vosges les voit
grandir ils partent à l'abattoir on les
travaille on les vend et c'est ça ce
casque est plus haut une journée par
semaine aurore se rend à une demi heure
de route de chez elle près de bourges
dans ce magasin quelqu'un avec d'autres
producteurs
bonjour
[Musique]
bon verrou tu veux je te remplace allez
messieurs dames 1 ici le consommateur a
le choix entre 1600 produits locaux en
vente directe ce qui fait un total de 75
euros 49 carte bleue
on vient toutes les semaines en grande
surface et le succès le sel et le poivre
puis ici c'est ce qui se mange qui a du
goût neuf agriculteurs sont associés
dans la gestion du magasin pour
commercialiser leur production et celle
des autres aurore est devenu incollable
sur le fromage de chèvre on doit
connaître tous les produits des autres
quelle affinage madame si l'essentiel
reste la vente de ses veaux pour aurore
les bénéfices du circuit court vont bien
au delà de l'aspect financier
les neuf associés que nous sommes dans
le magasin maintenant on est devenus une
famille on se connaît tous et puis les
clients il ya des clients ça va faire
dix ans qu'on se connaisse à faire dix
ans qui viennent toutes les semaines et
maintenant c'est un côté c'est un côté
familial avec les clients moi par
exemple ils m'ont vue enceinte dans le
magasin quand mon fils il vient mais
c'est votre petit voilà c'est devenu la
grande famille
l'échangé le partage c'est aussi ce que
cherchent les clients de la famille ben
dans le loiret 20% de la production de
yaourts et vendu en direct à la ferme
grâce à la mini usine de transformation
reprend contact avec nos consommateurs
qu'on a perdus dans les années 70 avec
l'apparition des grandes surfaces où il
fallait produire pour nourrir tout le
monde et le circuit de discussions assez
orienté vers les grandes surfaces on a
coupé le lien entre l'agriculture et le
consommateur
retisser ce lien perdu les consommateurs
n'y trouve que des avantages
j'aime bien l'idée de manger des
produits
directement de la ferme et donc j'ai dit
à ma soeur est ce que ça te dirait que
l'ombre pas cela et puis voilà
je pense sincèrement que les gens sont
plus respectueux par rapport à
déjà à l'animal
à l'environnement je pense que c'est
plus il ya plus de sincérité dans le
produit voilà c'est pour ça je fais ce
choix là mais je peux ça vous fait 12
euros s'il vous plaît c'est aussi la
simplicité en fait deux
des produits a beaucoup moins de
transformation dry le lait entier ont
les crèmes pas en rajoute pas d'autres
ingrédients c'est vraiment de rester sur
des produits naturels et le circuit
court ça permet vraiment bas aussi
d'être bien rémunérés correctement et ne
pas avoir un impact la grande
distribution à côté la famille ben
continue à vendre une grande partie de
son lait aux industriels
mais la vie à la ferme n'est plus la
même
ce qui change c'est le sait le rapport
aux consommateurs on est comme tout le
monde à en regarder la télé on entend
parler habiba ching tout ça on le veut
au moi je le vois je le véhicule pas
comme ça mais là avec le consommateur
qui vient qui est heureux de venir ils
demandent pas grand chose et ils
montrent comment les vaches y sont
caressés leveaux voir comment ils sont
nourris mais ils sont là ils sont
contents de venir on est content de les
recevoir un peu de discussions et voilà
c'est un truc un rouleau à sion
à tour sur le toit de notre hlm on
s'apprête à planter les radis qui se
retrouveront dans les assiettes des
locataires ce projet des jardins perché
germé dans la tête de tours habitat
était un véritable défi grâce aux
prouesses techniques des architectes il
n'y a pas eu de surcoût au mètre carré
et les appartements où très vite trouvé
preneur
dans les étals des supermarchés vous
avez du mal à comprendre les
légumes mais là vous voyez pouces et
donc forcément il ya un intérêt pour
voir un peu ce qui se passe au pied de
la résidence et dans les serres et puis
après il ya un échange qui se fait vous
savez que le maraîcher utilise le même
ascenseur que les habitants donc quand
vous descendez vos légumes qu'on est
maraîcher vous descendrez vos légumes
vous avez croisé à la mi-temps que dira
maintien c'est la saison des tomates
c'est la saison des salades vous avez
quoi comme salade et ses salades
batavias n'importe catherine la
gardienne de l'immeuble est une adepte
de la première heure dès ce soir ça va
être une salade avec une omelette et
puis avec le basilic avec une salade de
tomates aussi voilà des tomates que je
n'ai pas encore ici
[Musique]
en ville le circuit court est le fer de
lance de l'agriculture urbaine
cultivés sur le toit des immeubles une
idée trop peu exploitée
c'est vrai que c'est un espace qui est
non utilisés pour le moment est en fait
pourquoi reconstruire des serres et tout
ça deux endroits alors qu'on a des
espaces qui finalement les toitures ne
sont pas utilisés et qui ont finalement
tous leurs sens en fait dans
l'environnement urbain
retour auprès des fermes le magasin de
l'association des producteurs aurore
notre éleveuse effectué elle même la
découpe de sa viande de veau en chambre
froide suivre son animal du début à la
fin et plus valorisant et aussi beaucoup
plus rentables en circuits traditionnels
un broutards vous allez le faire partir
allez 700 euros
bon suivante si c'est un mâle femelle
bien sûr 700 euros et puis là en circuit
court quand vous avez tout détailler
tout valoriser votre animal et bien vous
allez vendre ça jusqu'à 1400 euros voilà
votre animal dont vous doubler si un
nombre croissant de consommateurs sont
convaincus par les circuits courts
restent producteurs à s'organiser
on est tous agriculteurs répartis dans
la campagne disperser et c'est pouvoir
offrir un seul endroit vraiment nos
produits et le haut c'est rentable c'est
que on partage un peu le coût de
l'infrastructure là où devraient chacun
peut-être avoir notre petit magasin le
tenir tout seul avec la strate l'avait à
travers un outil collectif on peut à un
moment donné à mutualiser les coûts
allez venez mais tu devenais honey bunny
fait ce qu'elle voudrait c'est que je
les change de chant pour avoir encore de
la meilleure herbe mais c'est non
l'essentiel de son temps aurore le pass
toujours auprès de ses limousines et de
leurs petits suis très fier et puis de
m'en sortir et de gagner ma vie parce
que fossiles voir comme ça on fait pas
j'ai un de mes collègues qui dit on
travaille pas pour 0 les paysans et oui
on travaille pas pour 0 moi je suis
contente de gagner ma vie grâce à mes
vaches et il voit là est d'aboutir à ce
que j'ai toujours voulu faire
je suis très très fier
rentable pour les agriculteurs vertueux
pour l'environnement est gratifiant pour
le consommateur les circuits courts ont
le vent en poupe mais réussiront ils à
se développer encore face à l'industrie
agroalimentaire
c'est un des défis de ce siècle